salut c'est jimmy et aujourd'hui c'est
en guyane que je vous emmène la guyane
qui a vu augmenter le nombre de cas liés
aux convives 19
je propose de partir à la rencontre de
violaines machichi prost qui vit nous
parlera de la situation là bas mais
aussi de ce qu'il ya de beau à faire en
guyane
[Musique]
salut violaine merci de nous accueillir
chez toi en guyane on va on va tout à
l'heure s'intéresser à la guyane à ce
qu'il ya de beau en guyane parce que
beaucoup d'antillais ne connaissent pas
forcément la guyane entendu parler on
des fois des idées préconçues sur la
guyane laisser imporant les piranhas et
compagnie mais connaissent pas les
beautés aussi de la guyane
on va y revenir tout à l'heure avant
vous voulez avoir des nouvelles comment
ça se passe chez vous on a cru voir aux
infos que la situation était très
compliquée par rapport au coût de 19
alors la situation s'est même accélérée
depuis quelques semaines maintenant à
partir du déconfinement les choses ont
été en déconfiture s'est opposé aux
abstractions liane nombre de cas a été
considérablement accéléré et a augmenté
aujourd'hui à l'heure actuelle je vous
racontais 1 384 cas dont près de 400 cas
on a longtemps été beaucoup moins
atteindre les antilles aujourd'hui on
rattrape la situation en la dépassant
elle donc sur ses 384 il y en a beaucoup
qui sont guéris déjà indépendante 156 ch
baptiste et depuis hier deux qui sont en
réanimation et une quinzaine en tout si
je n'ai pas de bêtises hospitalisé donc
en fait ça peut paraître bizarre mais en
fait moi c'est pas une surprise pour moi
puisque la vague la vague qu'ovide
arrive par l'est de la guyane c'est à
dire à la frontière du brésil et la
situation brésilienne mais aujourd'hui
dramatique
donc en fait le temps on a été confiné
vous sauver un petit peu en deçà des
chiffres nationaux et internationaux et
c'était juste le temps que la situation
brésilienne arrive juste jusqu'au bout
entière j'imagine que c'est compliqué
parce que c'est des habitudes aussi
qu'ils se sont installés en dix années
dans la région d'aller d'un pays à
l'autre d'aller de revenir donc c'est
très compliqué aujourd'hui peut-être
d'imposer sa aux populations
c'est compliqué parce que c'est une
c'est une façon de vivre si vous voulez
de tout temps les gens on était d'une
rive à l'autre et on les familles vivent
d'une rive à l'autre souvent pas les
enfants sont nés d'un côté pour à
l'école belloc par exemple donc cette
année sont sur l'équerré donc penser le
confinement version dual être cédés
chose à adapter sont pas toujours très
simple en france et j'ai bon allez en
parler des super bonne chose maintenant
c'est fait on va s'intéresser à la
guyane qu'est ce qu'il ya de beau
de bien à faire un en guyane dans les
antilles est malheureusement
méconnaissent la guyane à part ceux qui
sont déjà venus bien évidemment et qui
est souvent vont adorer la guyane qu'est
ce que tu nous conseillerais de devoir
de faire si on venait ici en guyane il
ya énormément chose à faire est la
première richesse selon moi c'est sur
l'interculturalité
un exemple tout bête vous allez au
marché de cayenne donc la ville capitale
entre lecture de la guyane vous pouvez
en moins d'une heure vers le tour du
monde au niveau culinaire vous pouvez
décider de manger monde chinois
brésilien a loupé ou amérindiens si vous
allez sur le sur d'autres marchés en
guyane
donc c'est vraiment c'est ce brassage
des populations ce brassage des cultures
c'est un vol quotidien sans arrêt qui
permet de découvrir un territoire
finalement mondiale sur un tout petit
moment et puis la forêt qui est
magnifique les îles du salut aussi je
point les ai laissés aller oui oui
attend on reste sur un territoire
amazonien on est quand même le seul
territoire français avec la forêt
amazonienne poumon de la terre vous
allez à - 2h02 de cayenne vous pouvez
aller aux îles du salut et vous allez
avoir l'eau bleue comme aux antilles du
coup on sait juste que ont choisi pour
le marron ou l'eau la rivière tout
simplement vous allez regarder avant
deux heures de bateau
vous êtes complètement déconnecté des
habitudes et des addictions de notre vie
citadine
il ya un petit village que moi j'adore
particulièrement ses singles c'est connu
que au centre de la guyane et sa garde
toute son authenticité avec ses maisons
créoles cesser ses habitants qui sont
adorables et c'est que la forêt
environnante que c'est bien et on voit
bien derrière à quel point ces luxueux
en ayant derrière toi merci beaucoup
violaine d'avoir pris le temps nous
parler de la guyane on espère que ça ira
de mieux en mieux chez vous en tout cas
aussi en courant et bon courage prudent
sur tout et pire on viendra c'est promis
en guyane merci pour ce beau voyage très
bientôt
voilà c'était un petit détour par la
guyane où la situation semble être
préoccupante on espère bien évidemment
que ça s'arrange on salue d'ailleurs les
martiniquais qui sont partis s'installer
en guyane s'était confiné d'ici et
d'ailleurs on se retrouve très très vite
sur la première à très bientôt
[Musique]